uh welcome well what i want to do now is
actually i'm going to use a this this
graphing application uh to to explore
the the trigonometric functions or
explore the graphs of them and just to
start off just let you know this this
i'm this application i'm using is from
gcalc.net it's
gcalc.net it's not mine but i want to
give them credit because that's what i'm
using and i hope they don't mind
so let's start off just graphing some
functions let's start off with the sine
function so let's say sine of x i hope
y'all can see it see i'm i'm typing it
in up here so sine x let me graph that
look at that look how nice that looks so
let's interpret this so
it's oscillating between
well let's just let's just go point by
point i guess it's the easiest way to do
it so at when x is equal to zero
what is the value of this function
well if we look here the value of the
function is let me actually
trace it
when x equals zero and it hasn't written
down at the bottom of this gray area so
when x
when x is zero
y
is also zero and if you remember when we
looked for the the definitions in the
unit circle that's what we got that the
sine of zero radians
is
zero
and now as we move on
or move along the curve i have the trace
function on
this is when
x is equal if we look in the gray area
at the bottom left it says 1.57 but what
is that
if if you're familiar with
the
1.57
is more commonly known as what it's half
of what famous number right it's half of
pi or this is we're at pi over 2
and if you want to convert pi over 2 to
degrees that's 90 degrees
so when we're at the angle of pi over 2
radians the sine function is equal to 1.
and if you go back to some previous
modules you'll remember that that's
exactly what the sine function was equal
to when we looked at the unit circle
because we were essentially at the point
1 comma 0. i hope it's not confusing
that i keep referring to the unit circle
that you can't see but we'll keep we'll
keep going
but one thing i want to introduce here
is the concept of
the period or the frequency of this sine
function notice it's pretty obvious to
pretty to you at this point that the
function keeps repeating itself right it
goes it goes from zero moves up to one
goes back to 0 goes down to negative 1
then goes back to 0 and then repeats
again
so the period
of this periodic function because that's
what we call a function that keeps
repeating the period of this periodic
function is this distance from here
to here
and what's that well that's 2 pi radians
and does that make sense well sure
because 2 pi radians is one complete
revolution around the unit circle and
then it repeats again
and it goes the other way you go two pi
radians backwards and things start
repeating again pretty interesting right
let's and and oh and another thing
notice that what what two numbers that
oscillate between it oscillates between
positive 1
and negative 1. and that makes sense
because in the unit circle
you can never get to a point on the
perimeter of the unit circle that's
larger than positive 1 or less than
negative 1 and that's why the sine of x
keeps oscillating between these two
points
let's do the cosine of x and actually
i'm going to leave the sine of x there
interesting it looks
almost the same
but
it looks shifted
it actually looks shifted to the left
about pi over 2 radians and that's
actually the case so so let's first
think about why
we figured out before that sine actually
it looks like this program is still
tracing the sine function that sine of
zero was zero
but if we look at the green function the
cosine of zero radians is actually one
and let me see if i can
see
now i see
i don't know how to trace the cosine
function so i'll just do it here the
cosine of 0 is 1. and why does that make
sense well the cosine is the x
coordinate on the unit circle
and when you have one radian
when you have 0 radians or zero degrees
you're at the point ones comma zero on
the unit circle so one
is the cosine or it's the x coordinate
and zero is the sine value and if any of
this is confusing review the video that
i where i use the unit circle to uh
solve the various values of the trig
functions and then this should make
sense and notice that this has a period
similar to the sine function right it
starts at 1 it goes down to negative one
and then comes back to positive one and
it takes
two pi
radians to complete that cycle
and just like the sine function it's
oscillating between one and negative one
because it can't really um
on the unit circle you can't get to a
point on the perimeter that's higher
than that
and now to to really hit the point home
let's do the tangent function i think
this is this one might
surprise you i'll look at that
so the blue line is the tangent function
and why does it do this crazy thing
well if you remember the tangent
function is equal to the y over the x on
the perimeter of the unit circle
and
or or since the y is the sine
is the sine and
cosine is the x it also equals the sine
over the cosine
so here tangent to zero whenever sine is
zero because that makes sense because
sine tangent is equal to sine over
cosine so it makes sense that when sine
is zero tangent is zero
but then
as the sine function becomes greater
and the cosine function becomes less
the numerator and the tangent function
becomes greater because the numerator is
sine so we get larger and larger values
all the way to the point where the
denominator
of the tangent function
or which is the cosine function i think
it's probably the most confusing module
i've ever said because i can't really
write these things down
the denominator goes to 0 right this
cosine right here and then tan spikes
and it actually approaches infinity and
if you look back at the at the unit
circle
that actually might make a little bit of
sense but like the other functions
actually tan
the tangent function has a period
of pi instead of pi over 2. instead of 2
pi and i'll leave that as an exercise
for you to think about
but with that drawn out i'm not going to
explore something else let me reset this
yes i really want to reset
i drew the sine function before
let me
draw the sine of let's say 2x
whoops that's not right
sine of 2
maybe i need to put some parentheses in
oh there we go actually let me reset it
yes i want to reset so first i'll draw
the sine of x
and then i'll draw the sine
of 2x
so what's the first thing you notice
about the the difference between these
two the brown one is sine of x and the
green one is sine of 2x
well they both have they both oscillate
between the same two numbers and just so
you know that this the the the height of
the oscillation is called the amplitude
of this periodic function so in both
cases the amplitude is one because they
oscillate from one to negative one so
the amplitude is one
but their period
is different
sine of x
takes
two pi radians to complete one circle
one cycle
while sine of two x
only takes pi radians to complete one
cycle so it actually completes it uh
twice as fast and i want you to sit and
think about why sine of 2x has half the
period of sine of x
and you could probably guess what
happens if i type in sine of 3x
actually let's do sine of 4x it should
be it should have half the period of
sine of 2x then and it does even though
this is probably a very um
confusing graph
so let's explore so i think you
understand what the coefficient of the x
term does when you have a larger
coefficient it kind of speeds up the
cycles
and let's let's let's explore a little
bit more
let's start off with sine of x again
and now instead of making the
coefficient larger let's make the
coefficient less let's make it sine of
0.5 x
look at that now all of a sudden it
takes four pi radians to complete one
cycle and i want you to think about why
that is because we're now slowing down
how fast it cycles through the angles
now i want to start playing with the
amplitude
so we had sine of x
right
what do you think will happen if i put
in 2
2 times
that's 2 times sine of x
so here
the period is the same it's still 2 pi
but notice that it oscillates between 2
and negative 2 instead of between
1 and negative 1. so whatever the
coefficient or whatever the number is in
front of the the sign or the cosine
function that actually affects its
amplitude and similarly we can look at
0.5
sine let's say 0.5 sine of
2x
interesting so now it only goes up to
0.5 and down to minus 0.5 so it's so
it's its amplitude is half one half or
0.5 and it's also oscillates twice as
fast as a sine function because it was
0.5 sine of 2x
i think that's all the time i have now
i have a feeling this might have
confused you more than helped but i'll
still
put the video up just in case it's
helpful for someone but in the future i
might actually record another video
where i can actually write things down
so it doesn't confuse you as much so if
i confuse you i apologize but i i hope
it was helpful
see you later